[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs à vis de vous retrouver pour ce
trentième numéro plein d'idées sorties
en plein air le sommaire de ce jeudi 25
avril depuis le 30 mars le château de
dampierre a rouvert les greens de son
parc 374 hectares à découvrir en famille
entre miroir d'eau et jardins à la
française d'andré le nôtre sur la
mélodie des oiseaux parc forestier ligne
baladeront sur ses terres d'une de
luynes laurent voulzy chanter le pouvoir
des fleurs elles sont mises à l'honneur
chaque année à la ferme du man est notre
invité du jour vous présentera cette 16e
édition de la prairial la spa de plaisir
s'associe à des étudiants de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines pour cette dixième édition du
canicross une course avec son fidèle
compagnon ou l'un des chiens du refuge
elle aura lieu ce dimanche 28 avril le
château de dampierre a rouvert les
portes de son parc
une nouvelle balade au coeur de la
vallée de chevreuse à découvrir en
famille nicolas gendry emprunté une
voiture est au beau milieu d'un parc
forestier de la vallée de chevreuse la
nature se laisse écouter on est au coeur
de la campagne et donc du coup quand on
sait oiseaux si on a de la chance est
arrivé quelques fois où aller chevreuil
pas si plat et puis on ne s'est vue sur
le château isolé au calme
le château de dampierre a rouvert son
parc au public depuis le 30 mars il
offre une balade familiale sur un
territoire à l'histoire royal l'histoire
c'est la famille de luynes qui devient
duc de chevreuse et qui à partir de ce
moment-là veut construire le château
avec jules hardouin mansart qui permet
bien après cette famille d'imposer son
pouvoir sur cette vallée de chevreuse et
d'y recevoir la cour de versailles
un aménagement permet aujourd'hui des
balades en calèche en rosalie on
voiturette de golf et même sur l'eau sur
les pas de louis 15
imaginez des chaloupes qui depuis le
château sont arrivés avec des
embarcations de part et d'autre et une
grande fête a eu lieu ici est donc cette
ce pavillon sur l'île
vraiment extraordinaire il faut qu'il
soit restauré évidemment mais il est
vraiment extraordinaire parce que c'est
cette petite folie posé au milieu de
l'île
ma petite folie
mon petit grain de fantaisie
surprise dans les hangars un ensemble de
calèches des voitures hippomobiles sont
conservées cinq d'entre elles sont
exposées au public en attendant
l'ouverture prochaine d'un musée dédié
donc du coup on a explosé et bien
découpés de gala des calèches jusqu'au
break de chasse qui était tout le train
hippomobile pour la vie quotidienne des
ducs et duchesses de lune au xixème
siècle le château de dampierre était
fermé depuis 2016 les yvelinois peuvent
de nouveau investir c'est patrimoine et
1749 c'était toujours un moment en fait
très privilégié parce qu'on passe et
voir en ce moment à un pique-niqué
ensuite à jouer au football donc j'ai
vraiment des souvenirs comme enrichi de
nouveaux souvenirs qu'il se construit
dans ce parc en attendant l'ouverture du
château lui-même ses travaux de
rénovation sont actuellement à les tuer
c'est l'un des rendez vous du printemps
à montigny le bretonneux organise depuis
16 ans par le leinster loeb est la
commune la prairial la fête des fleurs
et des jardins revient ce week-end
marie-laure pas tout vous êtes en charge
de cet événement bonjour bonjour alors
les prêts real sait combien d'exposants
qui expose quoi nous avons cette année
53 exposants qui sont sur trois secteurs
différents
les fleurs les plantes les produits
gourmands et l'artisanat
alors les fleurs les plantes qu est-ce
qu on y vient rajouter des plantes tout
à fait c'est à dire fleurs et plantes on
a vraiment une diversité au niveau 2 des
pépiniéristes des horticulteurs qui
présente à la fois des fleurs des
plantes au niveau du maraîcher aussi des
arbres de toutes sortes
il y a aussi une partie qui est plutôt
de la décoration au niveau 2 de
planteurs de tables de chaises qui sont
en fer forgé donc ça c'est aussi une
autre partie donc il ya vraiment une
grande diversité
il ya des nouveautés cette année alors
les nouveautés on a entre autres une
exposante qui présente des produits bio
du pissenlit des orties qui sont à la
fois en fleurs séchées ou en poudre et
donc il va nous expliquer quelles sont
les meilleures méthodes pour se servir
de ses nouveaux produits
alors l'objectif toujours d'avoir le
plus de monde possible parce que
derrière l'argent vous le récupérer vous
le donner une appréciation de
chiens-guides exactement puisque c'est
vraiment une action humanitaire
donc tout l'argent qu'ils récoltaient
par rapport aux exposants et à nos
visiteurs que nous souhaitons nombreux
l'argent est versé sur pour la lutte
contre la nécessité nous vous faisons ya
cinq chiens qui ont voilà exactement
donc 16e prairial veut dire donc de
nombreuses années et nous avons réussi à
récolter assez d'argent pour avoir cinq
chiens que nous avons pu donner à des
habitants toujours de la région
or justement puisqu'on est dans les
animaux une kia des plans des produits
gourmands des artisans d'art tout ce
petit monde à la ferme du manet avec
même des animaux des lapins voilà cette
année nous avons des lapins
donc lisez les enfants sont très
demandeurs de ce style de d'animaux ou
de produits pour les parents même pour
les enfants voilà vous parlez de fête
des fleurs justement c'est une fête
c'est convivial
oui puisqu'on a aussi pour les enfants
le poney club qui sera présent le samedi
après midi
il ya une partie aussi restauration pour
qui est proposée sur les deux jours et
c'est vraiment mettre en avant au
printemps tout ce qu'on peut le faire
dans son jardin mais comme je disais en
introduction le rendez vous du printemps
merci marie devenue sur notre plateau
merci donc l'après el 2010 neuf si ce
week-end des 27 et 28 avril à la ferme
du manet retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site internet dédié
on reste dans un univers champêtre avec
un atelier cueillette sauvage et cuisine
l'hôtel le bar la bonne elle vous
propose de vous balader dans son domaine
avec une experte pour découvrir les
bienfaits des plantes sauvages
après cueillette vous pourrez fabriquer
votre pesto sauvage bien sûr avec le
chef cuisinier vous pouvez vous inscrire
sur le site internet de l'établissement
d'autres ateliers sont proposés toute
l'année une fois que les plantes n'ont
plus de secret pour vous après cet
atelier cueillette et 7 prairial si vous
habitez magny les hameaux pouvaient
participer au concours maisons et
balcons fleuris
vous avez jusqu'au 1er juin pour vous
inscrire résultats du concours lors
d'une cérémonie officielle le 4
septembre
allez maintenant on rentre au foyer le
musée de la ville sort de ses placards
une partie de sa collection d'objets
design une rétrospective à l'odeur de
madeleine de proust pour présenter ces
objets du quotidien avec lesquels on a
grandi du réfrigérateur de la marque
frigidaire des années 50 au moulin à
café moulinex des années 70
la cuisine fait partie des quatre
thématiques de l'exposition avec
l'hygiène les nouvelles technologies et
le confort frédéric debussche directeur
du musée de la ville au micro de mélanie
poquet c'est un musée que sont reconnus
pour être avant tout un musée de
territoire qui est née en même temps
qu'eux
nouvelle mais c'est aussi un musée donc
un musée de france avec une collection
et notamment une collection design de
mode de vie qui est riche de 3000 objets
donc le but ici à travers cette
exposition est tout simplement d'en
présenter une sélection donc à peu près
80 90 objets qui sont le sélectionner
parmi cette collection des 3 millions le
nouvel épisode de la saga avengers est
sorti ce mercredi 24 avril nous sommes
nous sommes allés recueillir vos
impressions en sortie de sel c'était de
moins que sting un hameau 2,15 à la
normale était au faîte à l'asec s'était
vu lors des premières séances et le plus
qu'une place
on a eu les larmes qui montent est quand
même à de nombreuses reprises
et pas mal a énormément d'action et je
crois que c'est tout ce qu'on attendait
de ce film on pouvait pas deviner ce qui
allait se passer
on avait beau prévoir et mettre des
théories aucune était vraiment très bien
c'est white house
ce sens
en vrai marvel nous a vraiment j'ai
enfin ils nous ont jamais déçu non pas
comme les autres enfin c'est toujours
assez magnifique
c'est ce type de film c'était très bien
les effets spéciaux les jeux de combat
non non tout était tout était très bien
à certains moments du film vraiment très
triste
ascenseur émotionnel je dirais le dit le
décrire le film de faire des foulées
avec son chien c'est ce que vous
proposez la spa de plaisir depuis dix
ans avec l'organisation du canicross
l'idée de partager une course avec vos
canidés et ceux du refuge
pour cette dixième édition les coureurs
sont invités à se déguiser cette année
la spa a reçu l'aide étudiante en
management de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
les dossards sont déjà tous distribués
mais vous pouvez toujours y assister et
pourquoi pas avoir un coup de foudre
pour l'un de ses toutous à adopter le
principe donc ça fait dix ans qu'on le
fait c'était de courir avec des chiens
du refuge et de mélange et donc des
chiens du refuge et des chiens de
particulier donc ces deux voilà c'est
tout à fait festive c'est de courir dans
une bonne ambiance
et puis de mélanger un petit peu et puis
de montrer que les chiens de la spa sont
aussi sportif et qu'ils peuvent apporter
quelque chose
allons chercher la petite bête au musée
des arts décoratifs de paris
[Musique]
dans mon oreillette faut réaliser cette
émission j'ai xavier le scarabée jules
la libellule sandrine la lutine et roman
le lapin magicien et apparaît vous
pouvez retrouver les classiques mireille
l'abeille et siméon le papillon dans une
exposition dédiée à ces drôles de
petites bêtes
reportage de nos confrères via grand
paris entonne krings ce nom ne vous dit
peut être rien pourtant il est une star
de la littérature jeunesse avec des
personnages et des histoires qui résonne
dans les têtes de beaucoup d'enfants
quand mireille l'abeille ou barnabé le
scarabée les dessins de l'artiste se
retrouve au coeur de la nouvelle
exposition drôles de petites bêtes du
musée des arts décoratifs
un rendez-vous frais et printanier qui
devrait ravir toutes les générations
car l'expo mail le monde d'automne
krings et l'histoire de l'art ce qu'on a
voulu faire au musée des arts décoratifs
celle encore plus loin parce que quand
on regarde l'oeuvre d'anthony crise on
voit de vrais rapports avec l'histoire
de l'art en général devraient passerelle
être de grands artistes donc on a voulu
montrer à la fois les dessins originaux
d'antonne crise et ses inspirations
le but c'est vraiment de montrer que la
littérature jeunesse est l'illustration
jeunesse c'est un art à part entière et
que c'est pas parce que cet artiste
s'occupe de jeunesse que c'est pas un
grand artiste et on a vraiment voulu le
replacer dans l'histoire de l'art pour
mieux comprendre son travail construite
en six parties l'exposition s'articule
autour des thématiques des oeuvres
d'antonne krings que ce soit le jardin
les animaux ou la littérature
chaque pièce est à la fois composé de
dessins de l'artiste et de tableaux de
maîtres de l'art pour que l'exposition
reste agréable et accessible aux enfants
la scénographie mise en place par le
musée a aussi été pensé pour eux le
propos de l'exposition est assez
scientifique donc c'est vraiment une
exposition d'histoire de l'art est il la
volonté dans ton screens et du
scénographe c'était d'avoir un parcours
un peu plus ludique pour les enfants des
petite porte des petites fenêtres des
petits sons vers lesquels s'approcher et
c'est vrai qu'on espère que les enfants
sont très réceptifs à cet aspect plus
ludique et passeront un bon moment au
musée et on pouvait pas mettre à le
travail d'anthony quinn à l'honneur sont
proposés les livres et dans l'exposition
pourra donc voir les originaux mais
aussi se poser un petit peu pour relire
les livres 1
i dollars des animaux et de la nature
drôles de petites bêtes n'attend plus
que vous plus que 8 septembre prochain
et c'est la fin de votre 7,8 loisirs
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles et des sorties
non
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]